hi so we're ready to start our second
talk of the for this session it will be
about compression of quantum multi
proven interactive proof by a same thing
thank you so yes I talk about
compression of kanomata proven to prove
and i'll start with my last slide from
last year's qi p where i proved a creamy
harness 404 in tank in 10 games and in
last question open problem that it asked
is whether we can go beyond khmer and
actually this will be the central topic
of today's talk so the overview of talk
is first we discussed motivations and
some background of this topic and then
we briefly give you some ideas of main
steps of the proof and then but i've
spent about 10 minutes to give you some
of the more details in techniques and
proof and then we be freaking clue so
basically we are interesting knowing how
hard are non local games and this has
been a problem that has been puzzled us
for a long time even though i guess it's
fair to say that we even after this talk
prob'ly still unsolved but we have
something interesting to tell you this
is a class that we don't even know how
to hear that it's decidable even with
some precision that you can tolerate so
there is always the possibility that it
comes harder and harder and and we will
see that it's happening in this talk so
what are our LAN local games these are a
very simple model which has connections
to bear inequalities and also in
computer science we talk about multi
problem tariffs basically you will have
a very fair talk into multiple prefers
who can share entanglement into
measurements on their systems and the
Vera was sent for dispersion
pi over the question sets and and send
our questions to Allison Bob then the
verb receive answers back from the from
the players and and there would be a
function V defining the probability that
the welfare would accept or not based on
the questions and answer period the
important value of the thinnest coat
so-called non-local value which is the
optimal winning probability the optimal
acceptance property of the observer free
and when we when we talk about a local
game problem we are asking how hard it
is approximately this value to universe
pond on the precision you can consider
other approximating problems but in this
talk will focus in our universe Panama
approximation problem and our
tattoo is about quittin multipro
internship roofs but most of time we
were talking about non-local games they
are essentially the same thing but the
main difference is the message size are
very different in other games the
message size are really log of the
problem size but in multiple injectors
we have / nominally are long bar bit
students there are other set of
differences for example in games we are
more concrete and for inter proofs is
for language and wants to select
probably near language there will be a
concrete game but but that's not that
important the important thing is a
message size are different and we
require took a compression of
interactive proofs because we are
transformed this interpret proof with
pronoun misogynist message to tune on
cocaine with log sighs message
so this is what we showed last year we
give 4 player protocol for Luke have
been a problem and therefore it's none
other games or our creamy heart the
basic technique that we use is proving
rigidity for some games based on
correcting codes so that we have the
ability to encode opponent witness state
and at the same time you can command the
players we can became regulate their
their measurements and this is nice
because we finally proved quinlan
complexity for this column game but
there's also a dark cloud hanging over
our head because in four colossal games
we know that there are NP hard and it's
in mp so the problem solved you know
exactly it simply complete problem but
there's no coupon known for the new
local games and so Khmer you might not
be the right answer for the complexity
of these games and we'll see that it did
its case this comes to our slide for the
last year and and and problem that
whether we can go beyond the curly
harness so if you think about the
problem that compressor causes that are
harder than Khmer you these are natural
classes dedicate that I can found the
Kami to you somehow put a separate
bility condition on the witness and its
continuing care me and we don't know
much how hard it is but yeah maybe you
can prove that nautical games are coming
to her this is a problem that I asked in
the creamy hard paper and maybe you can
prove that it's P P or Q am hard or as
in this talk i will show you that it's
at least piece based hard but when you
when you go up its tree you're feeling
more uncertain because classical games
and Glasco in Turkey proofs they have MP
and XP complexity respectively so
it could it be that Conan games is
already in XP hard this is really
unbelievable or even that you can come
to the top of the of the trillion and
seeing that non who claims or am I p
star hard but as it turns out that the
techniques that we will show you in this
talk for peace with harness would
automatically give you chemically star
harness so basically it's or you can
have but the problem is we don't know
how hard it's going by the store but
yeah at least we have some like correct
answer to this twist problem so the
ultralight no proof is we use some good
ideas from the analysis of column proofs
including ma and and the now the single
prove our case clear IP and and and of
course the rigidity without recent
developed in in multi prove our case so
we will use p space as an intermediate
go to us with our ideas but if you think
about the problem it's two very
challenging me and how can you prove
peace peace harness for this small size
games but you might change your mind if
i tell you that there's an class called
chromium which alternatively
characterizes RP space so your photo op
qma which is so clean and love MP you
have a set of quantum bits and you can
verify whether it's a proof of some
stigma not and for this kim am which is
introduced by merit and virtuous you
would have a similar structure but now
there will be interaction to modi will
send the first half of the proof which
is not the complete set of proof and
then afterward felipe running a bit and
without looking at the first part of
proof and marina send the second half he
may rotate the this can help the qubit
before sending then ah sir
whether to accept not let's give you a
quinone quadrazine dopey space and the
good thing is it's very similar to kill
me if you wanted to Celia creamy
modified and we are by a woman's theorem
the the two proof that also may receive
depending on on the on the random bit
there will be a local unitary difference
on the second part of proof so if
there's the biggest one and the modem
would apply the transformation w and
otherwise that nothing is done so this
is what we know and and so you may
wonder what whether we are done because
it's so similar to the chemi proof and
maybe we can use our previous proof or
kill me to tissue that nanako games are
kim am hard then peace bees hard so i
will remind you how we proved kill me
harness we would encode this included
call a witness proof using some simple
kinetic writing code and then you would
have for dumb people 42 code and you
would distribute approved into for
provers each holding one of the included
cubits from h cubed so the bone
technical are seen that if you want to
carry out this idea is in addition to
this rigidity that you can process
measurement of x and z you would now
have to apply you have to some other
rigidity without that you can you for
set out the you ask the previous two to
first apply the unitary w and then
measure right this is only other
ingredient that we need in this
extension to QMI am but then there's
this problem because after the including
you have distributed the proof among the
proof us and they are not commuting so
how can they apply this unitary if you
think about the problem essentially you
are you're asking the provost we to chew
the code so that you can you can do a
transversal universal connect
competition on data and and we know for
a long time that this is impossible so
this becomes the main challenge in
actually for our proof to go through and
because of this problem even honest
prove i won't be able to follow the
protocol first apply the w and then do
some measurement so there are two ideas
that we can fix this problem one is
actually if you look harder on watches
as proof of paralyzing conan inter jump
rope to three rounds three three
messages the the prover side is actually
across the computation now you wonder
whether you can have a universal and
transversal our case set for a
classically reversible universal
computation and i don't find any i guess
its own size no so now left with other
solution is whether we can do this thing
without any encoding but our previous
construction depend very heavily on the
Eric writing code structure so we have
to invent some new new new set of games
so that we can achieve ability without
encoding in the error-correcting sense
so three steps of the overlay avila
overall proof so the first we would
design some problem that place below
hablo common problem for care may and
this is essentially the you you you
would consider a history state of the
interaction for copy three and and in
this history state i use you as gates in
this interaction including v1 v2 and
this w
so now we would have to do two things
for food we would need to check that the
vert for propagation is correct and and
this is kind of easy using some similar
techniques could proving the Clifford
lecompton in problem as found to told
you and then the second part is is more
interesting that we have to make sure
that the propagation at the provo step
is correct for this we would we would
use and secure extended EP are games
that we went to do so later the next
step we would end up with extending the
local game from this honest player
setting viewed in riddle a 44 game that
we introduced called constraint
propagation game when the last step we
remove so exciting extended medical game
the Rivera some quantum is and we in the
last step we remove this requirement on
their first slide by delegating the
competition to some extra prefers right
so this is over a structure that we
prove that games are psp's hard and I
said that it's almost trivial to
generalize it to our my P star our
harness it is based on technique that
these people can pay kapoor ashima shoot
mishimoto verdict generalizes the Cure
p3 idea to the multipolar setting so we
would finally would prove that non-local
games or cure my P star complete and and
therefore it's an exp heart because the
bricks or without of e2 and varick
proving containment of an XP in a movie
star so if you'll notice that classic
games on P hard then we are proving that
nanako games are probably harder than
classic games because NP is not equal to
an exp and also we provide a some strong
indication that the approximation
problem for the non-local value and
there's interesting trade-off between
the capacity of the cinder classically
because a PCP serum inverse pronoun me
approximation and constant approximate a
permission is the same harness but
quantum remove that it's not the case ok
so the techniques that we use is
basically the arm the idea of using
extended nanoka games instead of
non-local games to probe rigidity so
basic idea is you want to universally
the players to do the measurement you
first you do itself so the power of
external local games allow us to both to
prove the requirement that we want
rigidity without encoding and and the
check in the approver publication using
this extended DPR games so what are this
extended non-local games these are
generalization of non-local games which
it is by a Johnston mito Russell and
virtuous very recently so in local games
we have a question said answers on sets
and distributions and the wafer that
specifies the acceptance row of
reference which is a mapping of the
simple ability dispersion and then this
extended nanako game the V is function
to this operators are between 0 and
identity so you can think of it as a
measurement that you can you can perform
so there's another equivalent view of
this definition is you have now the Vera
has the corner system but the river
doesn't choose how to initialize the
state the proper choose the station of
the state but the vero can do to
measurement on the system before making
any decisions um so in when introducing
this concept of extending local games
essentially a generalization and and and
it's considered into at least two
players but we found that the single
player extended local games already very
interesting and Abu Abu focusing on this
so in that case you would have a
verifier who share some state the state
of children by
Hoover and the wafer do some measurement
in and one run interaction with approval
the first extend a local game that we
are considering is called the
propagation game and we'll to define
this publication game you would have set
of reflections are 12 RN and also a
sequence of our productions for each of
the entry would be one of these and
reflections and then you arrange this
sequence of reflections on the chain
basically we think of this as a
propagation of some computation and
obviously any of the case or a
refraction and and this propagation gain
is a extended local game where the
referee has a quantum system whose size
is determined by the number of time
steps that you have and essentially are
tracking whether the publication is
correct so how do you check that the
petition to correct the the wafer would
randomly choose an edge and do a
measurement to see whether a system is
in this edge or outside edge if outside
except automatically it's in ennis edge
for example 2 and 3 then you measure X
on this two basis and ended you can
check whether the state on time step 2
and x time step 3 is related by
reflection are two so somehow this is a
nano game version of propagation chair
clean like Korea may or history state
constructions and then we can prove
something about this application game
basically if you can consider this
definition of history state then if you
want to win this game with optimal
property which is one then you have to
choose a cursory States
and then we would also introduced a
slightly more complicated version of
this game called constraint propagation
game in to define this we will have
again reflections and a set of
constraints so the constraints would be
of this product form whether the product
is identity or minus identity so from
this constraints you you stretch
sequence by ticking the reflections from
c1 and c2 and so on and this give you a
publication chain and then you also
consider our constraint chain where for
example if c1 is the accumulator of two
nr1 then you would have this blue chain
connecting 0 and for you essentially
what you're checking is whether the
state at time 0 and 10 for are the same
state after the progression of r2 r1 r2
r1 so roughly you would do to
propagation games and that is that you
you check the constraints are correctly
satisfied on the state and then we can
show that if the if the prover want to
win almost surely then the constraints
had to be satisfied approximately on on
the state that the prover chooses but
yeah technically the work we have to you
have to consider a state that initially
at the time step 0 right so but to prove
this multi multi cubed rigidity are
using this appears to construction we
have to consider to enhancement to the
propagation games and constraint
propagation games so basically you would
allow two extensions one is the sukkot
confusion questions are with you have
two indices GN q q is a subset of the
qubits G is one of the elements in this
subset the idea is that you sometimes
you want to ask
a bunch of qubits but only interested in
measurement down one of the qubit and
this will help us to relate single
measurement cubed measurement too much
cuban measurement and then the other
extension is we want to consider control
publications now the control cubed it on
the very far side and we have to make
sure that there's a history state that
propagating according to this controlled
reflections this is a technical
requirement that we need to prove this
rigidity without using a concept called
consistency we don't have consisted
anymore in this new construction which
is important in in previous concessioner
accrediting codes and then you with this
two extensions we are able to prove much
cubed rigidity for this some sort of
constraint propagation game so that you
can command the perverse to do
constantly poly measurements and and up
to summer sama tree so this is what do
we need but some discussion so why we
needed between enhancer or constraint
propagation game so basically the
constraint progression game would give
you approximate constraint on the state
in this form for them you can you can
prove that to the reflections are almost
approximately commuting aren't i
committing which will give you much of a
structure of the operators but
unfortunately it is not possible to
prove ability only with this set of
conditions and you would hear more about
this in I guess it's also in this is
creepy it's called overlapping qubits
right so in the second use of this
extended non-local game we would use it
to check the publication of the profits
that if you consider the only the
publication of the previous step you
would want to check whether the proof is
of this form 00 is the clock and and one
is after the application of W so
basically want to check by the stated of
this form and we would use the so-called
extended epr game where this access and
then there are the stepladder for the
EPR and the first column would be the
verify so Peters so the referee is
honest and can measure X and Z and for
the other acts and said we were
translated to 0 and 1 and send it over
and asked that proper to measured for us
and if you take the productive dead x
and z the first column would give you a
minus identity the second column we
don't know whether the prover would
actually do as the as we are asking but
at least for some reflection X some X
some that and and when you when you must
band together it will give you anti
committing relation on the prover sighs
so from this we we know that you can
prove really so this gives you us uses
some well-known technique that you can
prove rigidity from the antique motility
condition and and for this or this
argument to work we somehow need a Serie
of stabilizer from resin with some noise
approximates bit stabilizers and and
basically what we are saying that if you
do this game then you can check this
step this step is actually on the main
step that which is used in this creepy
paralyzation two three messages to
somehow this is a non-local version note
for this result
so to conclude we have told you about
how to compress a quantum multi proven
check proof to a nun who came with
messages of log bits and we prove that
it's come IP complete and in XP hard and
the proof is combination of several
areas in basically the history states
actually we use his fists accession
twice one in this history of her p 3 and
the other is in the propagation games
the second technique that is we use is
paralyzation of quantum proofs and of
course we need rigidity of non-local
games to two computer proof and I should
mention that there is a recent
breakthrough by William South sure you
hear this as as a pennant talk in this
friday morning and you will be telling
you that nano games are undecidable but
the difference between these two results
is that the newest ability without our
exact case there's no error that you can
tolerate and in our case we tolerate one
over party error and and we prove that
the when you when you have some error
you will be decidable so for open
problems now we know the hardness of
non-local games to 2 inverse poly
approximation to the question is what
harness for the constant preceding a
proclamation and as we told you that the
the trade-off between complexity and
precision might be different in the
current setting so what the weather
exactly is a trade-off and we and 22
completely resolve the hardness of this
nautical games we have to understand
what what is harnessed of MIP star and
we currently we don't have any a bound
on that okay thank you
[Applause]
okay so any questions for Zhang Feng
hi I think a lot of new techniques just
wonder if I want to compare your this
year work with your previous year's work
so you're dealing with the nearest
iteration now you have one more round in
the interrupt proof so so it just wonder
what are the new techniques handle which
part of the new feature is like you're
adding one prove ER and maybe adding one
round in the minerals what kind of
technique you handle which part you
guess the most challenging part is you
have to solve this transversality
problem that we have because after the
encoding the pervert cannot perform this
unitary that you want to apply on the
second run that you first incur p3 you
you first give part of the proof and
then after the challenge from the from
the welfare you have to adaptively
change in this witness state but then
you if you are including this thing you
won't be able to do that and this is
what we want to solve and we introduced
a lot of new ideas to do that ok so
basically the transversal allocates the
casing for free previous one to work but
now yeah you don't have any control on
the perverse eyes unitary yeah ok thank
you
any other question okay I have a
question actually so you said in your
last slide that you know the one of the
important question was to see the
difference between the count the
constant Europe and the inverse polygala
so the very similar question happened in
12 pcp typically so if you would show
for example that it's not the same
complexity is it so because you said
yeah it's related to life I think there
are several different flavors of quantum
PCP conjecture and and one that we are
turning talking about is is basically in
the framework of non-local games but the
connection between this you can also
consider like clear may prove in a more
are PSP flavor you have a bunch of
quantum bits and and cubits and you want
to verify but then the connection
between these two different versions are
not known classically they are
equivalent but currently we don't know
maybe there will be some inside provided
to this other definitions but we still
don't know okay thanks any questions
okay so let's thank the speaker again
you